Heute im Rasenfunk? Also eigentlich wollte ich meine Version dieses Chingis machen, wo der italienische Kommentator, also der schreitet die ganze Zeit durch und ich wollte eigentlich den Jingle fertig werden lassen und dann nochmal ganz leise nochmal diesen Schrei nochmal hochziehen. Vielleicht mach ich das demnächst. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen bei YouTube und alle Zuhörenden im Podcast. Hier ist der Rasenfunk, hier ist die Ligatur, neben mir sitzt Christian Bernhard. Hallo Christian.
Hallo Max.
Dann haben wir Uli Hebel hier. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Grüß dich und grüß euch.
Und wir haben Alex Truica hier. Hallo Alex. Wenn ihr euch fragt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wo die Liga bleibt, das fragen wir uns auch. Die Liga dieses Jahr hat sie es nicht in die Ligatur geschafft. Terminliche Probleme sind dafür der Grund. Wenn ihr jetzt sagt, Moment mal, ich brauche aber meine Dosis an vielen europäischen Ligen alle zwei Wochen, ansonsten schaffe ich das nicht. Da habe ich eine sehr gute Nachricht für euch. Ich habe am Dienstag allein eine Stunde zu Ajax Amsterdam aufgenommen und dem ganzen Chaos, das es da gibt. Also die Ligatur liefert, ohne dass ich das damals schon gewusst hätte, dass die Liga nicht erscheinen kann, hier zu diesem Termin. Also das könnt ihr gerne hören. Wenn ihr im Rasenfunk Ligatur-Feed seid, dann findet ihr das ganz einfach bei YouTube auch. Und generell lohnt es sich, auf rasenfunk.de zu schauen, denn wir bringen gerade so viele Sendungen raus, dass ich hier nicht mal alle ankündigen kann. Also heute Abend oder Nacht wahrscheinlich eher wird noch was zum Frauen-Nationalteam erscheinen. Bundesliga haben wir gemacht, ein Tribüngespräch gibt es neues. Und wahrscheinlich habe ich sogar noch was vergessen, denn ich habe sehr viele Sendungen gemacht. Naja, der Rasenfunk ist werbefrei, paywallfrei und sponsor unfrei. Bitte unterstützt uns, rasenfunk.de support das Club. Aber jetzt wollen wir reinblicken in die Europäischen Ligen. Und ich würde sagen, wir beginnen in La Liga. Denn da haben wir etwas, was durchaus selten geworden ist, zumindest ab den Spieltagen 5, 6, 7, nämlich einen neuen Tabellenführer, einen unbekannten Tabellenführer, einen Sensations-Tabellenführer, sagen wir es doch, wie es ist. Alex, wer grüßt uns da von der Tabellenspitze und warum werden sie ganz sicher Meister?
Völlig überraschend, ein Team aus Katalonien, aber nicht der FC Barcelona. Der FC Girona ist tatsächlich zum ersten Mal in der Vereinsgeschichte Tabellenführer. Sie waren ja noch nicht so häufig in der Liga, also im Oberhaus im Spanischen, das ist ein sehr, sehr kleiner Klub. Und ja, wir haben sechs von sieben Spielen, eins unentschieden gespielt, mit 19 Punkten sind sie Tabellenführer vor, Real Madrid mit 18 Punkten und Barca mit 17 Punkten. Also die anderen beiden, die sind da oben, aber Girona mit Abstand das Überraschungsteam. Schlechthin in Spanien, die machen richtig, richtig Freude. Also das ist schon eine beachtliche Geschichte in Spanien aktuell.
Also doch wieder Manchester City, wie immer.
Ich wollte es nicht gleich in der Anmoderation ansprechen, aber ich werde ja darauf angesprochen und ihr wisst das ja eh. Aber ja, die City-Club ist natürlich hinter Girona, hinten dran.
Was heißt denn da negativ? Das ist ja wie es ist.
Es ist wie es ist. Vor allem die Multi-Club-Owner-Chips, das wird so zunehmen. Jetzt haben ja die neuen Chelsea-Besitzer, die haben sich jetzt 500 Millionen Pfund, glaube ich, geholt. Und da steht schon mit drin, ja unter anderem auch für Beteiligung noch an weiteren Clubs. Also es ist jetzt nicht nur um die Schulden zu tilgen.
Es sollten alle weit laufen, die das hören und auf keinen Fall das Angebot annehmen.
Ey, Moment mal. Die haben bestimmt ganz viele Spieler, die es nicht geschafft haben, mit achtjährigen Verträgen, die dann…
Ja, das stimmt. Deswegen brauchen sie es, ja.
Da sollte Burghausen zuschlagen.
Sechsjährige Leihgeschäfte.
Ja, wo ist eigentlich der KFC Uerdingen, wenn man ihn mal braucht?
Es hält sich übrigens in Burghausen hartnäckig das Gerücht, dass Salzburg eigentlich nach Burghausen hätte kommen wollen. Nee, Leipzig andersrum, also sprich, es hält sich hartnäckig das Gerücht, dass Burghausen kurz davor war, sozusagen RB Leipzig zu sein. Keine Ahnung, ob es stimmt, aber…
Ja, aber gut, wir wissen ja, dass damals der dahinterstehende Konzern auch bei Fortuna de Soudal von St. Pauli angeklopft hat. Aber eigentlich reden wir hier über Girona. Das war eine nette kleine Schleife, wie sie so manchmal passiert. Ist denn das jetzt nur Spielplan-Glück, Alex, dass man da die entsprechenden Gegner hatte? Weil wenn ich mir so angucke, 5 zu 3 gegen Mallorca, 4 zu 2 gegen Granada, 1 zu 0 gegen Las Palmas, 2 zu 1 gegen Sevilla, okay, 3 zu 0 gegen Getafe. Aber so die ganz riesigen Namen waren da jetzt, mit Ausnahme von Sevilla, vielleicht nicht mit dabei.
Genau, die ganz riesigen waren nicht dabei. Die großen drei haben sie natürlich noch nicht gespielt, also Atletico, Barca und Real Madrid. Aber schon bei Real Sociedad, Champions League-Teilnehmer, letztes Jahr vierter, unentschieden gespielt, gleich zum Auftakt, glaube ich. Also das war ja schon recht beachtlich, weil normalerweise gewinnt Real Sociedad seine Spiele, wenn auch knapp zu Hause. Also sie sind schon sehr, sehr gut daheim. Und jetzt, just gestern Abend, haben sie in Villareal gewonnen. Ja, auch die Straucheln hatten schon einen Trainerwechsel, aber auch das musst du erst mal schaffen als so kleines Team. Und von daher, der Spielplan war nicht der schwerste, aber so zwei, drei Ausrufezeichen in Sevilla gewonnen. Ja, das ist seit einem Jahr ein bisschen leichter, aber trotzdem durchaus beachtliche Ergebnisse. Und ansonsten vor allem zu Hause machen sie richtig Spaß. Red Tape 3 zu Null überfahren, in Granada vier Tore geschossen, gegen Mallorca fünf Tore geschossen. Also das ist schon trotzdem beachtlich.
Und wer sind da so die entscheidenden Spieler? Müssen wir über den Trainer nennen. Wer wird denn bald bei City die Premier League aufmischen?
Ja, über den Trainer musst du natürlich sprechen, weil Michel sehr offensiv-minded Fußball spielen lässt. Also der lässt immer seine Mannschaft draufgehen, ist sehr mutig in seinem Ansatz. Also grundsätzlich steckt da auch der Trainer dahinter, der sich natürlich nicht versteckt oder nicht. Red Tape ist immer das große Negativbeispiel. Die mauern sich handballmäßig um den eigenen Strafraum, hauen alles um und versuchen irgendwie 0-0 mitzunehmen. Und vielleicht fällt ein Standard vom Laster und da gewinnt der 1-0. Ne, Girona hat wirklich einen aktiven Plan, geht drauf, presst früh. Ganz, ganz bemerkenswert ist, dass die Strafraumbesetzung, wenn sie im Angriff sind, also sie kommen gerne über die Außen, auf die Spieler komme ich gleich zu sprechen, und dann ist die Strafraumbesetzung richtig stark, dass sie dann immer mit drei oder vier Spielern im Strafraum auftauchen und so natürlich auch das ein oder andere Tor schießen, durch Cutbacks, durch Flanken, durch Abraller, die dann eben bei ihren Spielern landen. Also wirklich ein mutiges Auftreten, laufen viel, gehen drauf, spielen mit unglaublich viel Selbstvertrauen und das ist natürlich beim Trainer anzusiedeln, klar.
Und wer sind dann die entscheidenden Spiele?
Also da muss man die Flügelzange definitiv nennen. Sie spielen im 4-5-1 normalerweise, wobei natürlich mit Ballbesitz wird es dann eher in 4-3-3. Und da ist die Flügelzange rechts zu Gangkopf neu gekommen, vielleicht mit City Group Money, klar. Links Savio neu gekommen, sehr, sehr dribbelstarker Mann. Also beide schnell mit Ball, dribbelstark, offensiv freudig, wirklich schwer zu greifen und sind so ein bisschen die Entdeckung der Saison wie nicht bei den großen Clubs spielen. Also die beiden würde ich persönlich nennen. Herrera ist gekommen, auch der gehört, glaube ich, der City Group und wird ein bisschen hin und her geschoben seit Jahren. Jan Herrera. Und im Mittelfeld war zum Beispiel letztes Jahr schon Alex Garcia, einer der herausragenden Spieler. Sie waren ja letztes Jahr schon, ich meine, Achter. Und nur am letzten Spiel, da haben sie die Teilnahme an der Conference League verpasst durch ein einziges Spiel, wenn sie das gewonnen hätten. Also sie waren ja damals schon richtig gut unterwegs. Und da war zum Beispiel Alex Garcia so der Dreh- und Angelpunkt im zentralen Mittelfeld und auch in der Saison natürlich knüpfte voll an die starke letzte Saison an. Ja, das sind so die drei Namen, die ich herausstellen wollen würde aktuell.
Ja, ich meine, sie haben jetzt, also natürlich gibt es diese Verbindung zur City Group. Sie haben jetzt nicht wahnsinnig mit Geld um sich geschmissen, wobei halt gerade wenn du dann Neuzugänge halt aus der Group hast, ist es ein bisschen schwierig einzupreisen. Darf man nicht in die Leipzig-Falle der harten Verhandlungen mit Salzburg tappen. Ist denn das ein Thema überhaupt in Spanien oder freut man sich einfach, dass es ein bisschen anders ist als bisher, weil es ja wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann sich wieder drehen wird?
Das ist natürlich kein Thema, wenn du überraschst. Die Spanier gucken da nicht auf solche Dinge so genau. Das ist kulturell bedingt, glaube ich, alles immer so. Da wird hochgejubelt, ohne so genau unter den Teppich zu gucken, was da so los ist. Aktuell werden die vor allem natürlich von den katalanischen Magazinen Mundo, Deportivo und Sport hochgejubelt, weil es eine katalanische Elf ist. Der City Group ist nicht so das Thema vor allem, weil es ja in Spanien eh nicht ganz so gang und gäbe ist wie in der Premier League, aber die eine oder andere Mannschaft hat ja trotzdem den Schaich oder den Geldgeber in den Reichen. Peter Lim bei Valencia, über Malaga mit dem Kollegen Fabian Pakulat haben wir häufiger hier gesprochen. Da hat der Schaich den 1860 München-Move gemacht, die in die dritte Liga gehievt. Ich glaube, Granada, Almeria hat auch einen Schaich im Hintergrund. Also das ist auch ein bisschen in Spanien verbreitet und da wird nicht so genau hingeguckt.
Okay, aber dann grüßen wir an dieser Stelle den FC Malaga und Fabian Pakulat natürlich. Wir möchten darauf hinweisen, Dritter aktuell in der Tabelle und jetzt Jungs gewonnen. Ich glaube, er war sehr traurig, dass er nicht herkommen durfte. Genau, vier Siege in Folge.
Genau, er meinte irgendwas vier oder fünf Siege in Folge. Also da läuft es auch schon besser.
Das freut uns doch alle zu hören. Dann gibt es bald wieder hier den Malaga-Schwerpunkt. Dann ist die Frage, was man dann in der Premier League besprechen kann. Da haben wir jetzt zwar keinen Tabellenführer, aber wir haben Uli mit Tottenham ein Team. Das kam jetzt schon in der letzten Ligatur vor, weil wir da über Ansh Postociuclo kurz gesprochen haben als MVP. Aber dahinter steckt ja mehr. Vor allem ist es nachhaltig. Tottenham rang vier nach sechs Spielen mit 14 Punkten. Damit hat man vier Punkte Rückstand auf City. Und ist aber mittendrin in diesem Cluster aus City, Liverpool, Arsenal und natürlich Brighton, so wie wir es alle erwartet haben vor der Saison. Was macht denn Tottenham aus?
Ganz, ganz viel. Was früher nicht da war. Jetzt muss man ja auch mal schauen, wie nachhaltig es wirklich ist. Aber nachdem jetzt am Wochenende das Nordlondendaby war gegen Arsenal und da gewisse Dinge nicht so gut liefen bei Tottenham, traue ich mir jetzt mal zu, zu sagen, dass vieles von dem, was wir im Moment sehen, ist schon legit. Heißt, in allererster Linie ist Tottenham in den letzten Jahren regelrecht auseinandergebrochen, wenn irgendwas nicht lief. Oder auch wenn es lief, dann sagte man immer Spursy. Also es sind Dinge, die eigentlich schon sicher ins Ziel gerettet sein müssen, die dann plötzlich einfach noch nicht funktioniert haben. Und in dem Spiel haben sie auf vielen verschiedenen Ebenen ihre Widerstandsfähigkeit gezeigt. Also sprich, wenn sie in den ersten 40 Minuten überhaupt gar keinen Zugriff kriegen, überhaupt nicht ihr Spielsystem zum ersten Mal, je Z-Bus, je Kugel übernommen hat, überhaupt nicht durchgekommen sind, sich selbst keine Ballbesitzphasen haben erspielen können. Wenn sie extrem hart gepresst wurden vom Spielaufbau, von hinten her haben sie dann Lösungen gefunden, sind trotzdem auf ihre Weise dann ekelhaft geblieben sozusagen. Auf der anderen Seite aber auch, wenn es dann Rückschlag gibt, also zum Beispiel ein Handelfmeter, als es eigentlich gerade für sie läuft, kommen sie trotzdem wieder zurück und fangen an zu spielen. Selbst wenn dann einer raus muss, der einer der wichtigsten Spieler ist wie James Madison, finden sie dann Lösungen. Und das ist schon mal erstaunlich, dass es etwas da muss, der Trainer gewirkt haben. Das geht nicht anders, weil, wenn ihr euch erinnert, als wir das letzte Mal hier über Tottenham gesprochen haben, war noch Konter da und alles war dermaßen verschüttet, dass niemand das mehr auffischen konnte. Und das ist erstaunlich, finde ich, in so kurzer Zeit, dass der nächste, nächste Neuanfang bei Tottenham ohne Kane schon zu so vielen Erfolgen führt. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch ein paar spielerische, spieltaktische Gründe, die ebenfalls entscheidend sind. Also muss man schon sagen, wie schnell implementiert worden ist, wie schnell auch angenommen worden ist, dass von hinten rausgespielt wird. Poste Koglo lässt ganz oft über den Platz verteilt in vielen Vierecken spielen, kommt also sozusagen über die Breite in die Tiefe die ganze Zeit. Das macht er wirklich erstaunlich gut. Eingeklappte Innenverteidiger, die dann auf den Halbspuren wahnsinnig gefährlich nach vorne laufen und ganz oft einfach nicht zu greifen sind für Gegner.
Aus einer Viererkette raus.
Aus einer Viererkette raus, ja. Breite Außenverteidiger. Torwart, also Vicario Christian wird den wahrscheinlich gekannt haben. Ich nicht. Ich bin total verliebt in den Typen, weil ich glaube, die haben den absoluten Jackpot geholt. Der kann Fußball spielen und ist ein Shotstopper. Also alles, was alle gerade suchen. Und das Ganze für unter 30 Mio. Keine Ahnung, wo sie den her haben, aber der gefällt mir außerordentlich gut. Und dann ist es genau so, nämlich, dass die ganz variabel sind. Also es kommt immer einer kurz. Sie drehen das Feld permanent so. Also geben dem permanent so einen leichten Anstrich, dass es nach links und nach rechts wabern kann. Die Außenverteidiger gehen in die Halbspur. Destiny Odogi, auch den wird Christian ganz gut kennen. Auch einer von Odegnese gekommen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum ich noch nie von dem hörte vor der Saisonvorbereitung. Der marschiert dann zum Beispiel völlig durch. Und dann haben sie auch noch mit Madison Zehner, der extrem kreativ ist. Sie haben mit Sonn inzwischen den Nummer 9, der trifft wieder. Also auch der, der gar keine Form hatte unter Antonio Conte. Also nach sechs Spielen, soweit man das zulässig ist, sieht das sehr, sehr gut aus.
Das wollte ich gerade auf Udodji ansprechen. Ich finde es überraschend, wie schnell der da, wie fest der da schon drin ist quasi und wie gut er da anscheinend auch drin funktioniert. Also, athletisch war immer klar, dass er das mitbringt, aber dass der dann gleich von Anfang an da auch sozusagen als Stamm-Links-Verteidiger so funktioniert, schätze ich mal, wird in London auch etwas vielleicht überraschend wahrgenommen werden, oder?
Ja, ganz sicher. Also, da hatte niemand auf dem Schirm. Das ist ja das erstaunliche Thema bei ihm auch, dass er ja eigentlich fast offensive only ist. Also, keiner, der ernsthaft defensive anbietet. Und da hatte ich schon auch gedacht, dass es vielleicht insbesondere gegen Arsenal dann Probleme geben könnte, aber ist gar nicht der Fall. Sondern es sieht so aus, als würde der sich einfach reinbeißen, egal was ist. Und natürlich schon auch einer, der vom System lebt, gerade weil er halt erstens ran durfte aufgrund seiner Athletik, zum zweiten auch, dass in diesem Kader ansonsten jetzt auf der Position nicht viel los ist. Pericic ist jetzt auch wahrscheinlich Saison aus aufgrund Kreuzbandrisses. Dann hast du noch Ben Davis, das kann man vergessen bei Posti Koglu, glaube ich. Das wäre eher ein Innenverteidiger, wenn er ihn brauchen würde. Aber mal losgelöst von dem, das sieht so nach All-Action aus. Also einer, der wirklich die ganze Zeit einfach macht und tut und das alleine hilft dir schon mal enorm weiter, dass Tottenham das jetzt so schnell implementieren konnte.
Also Udoti von Udiné gekommen und Vicarrio von Empoli.
Von Empoli, ja, weil Uli es schon anspricht. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein Glücksgriff, weil der ist total bodenständig. Der war schon die letzten Jahre in Italien. Es war immer klar, dass das der nächste wird. Es gibt auch immer wieder Gerüchte. Wenn Donnarumma sich noch den einen oder anderen Fehler mehr leisten sollte in der Nationalmannschaft, dann ist Vicarrio da. Das wissen auch alle. Vicarrio war auch bei Inter auf dem Zettel. Der war halt zu teuer. Ich glaube, was Uli zu seinen Qualitäten gesagt hat, dass er auch ein Junge ist, der wirklich total am Boden ist. Ich glaube, mit dem werden noch viele sehr viel Spaß haben. Das ist ein Torhüter, der auf lange Zeit dominieren kann.
Ich habe den Namen schon auch immer gelesen und eben auch bei Inter. Ich hatte den nie so auf dem Schirm für jemanden, der alles vereinen könnte. Ich habe gesagt, das ist eine Art Allison. Der Tor hat den alle suchen, der einfach alles kann und gar keine Schwäche hat.
Ich sehe sie nicht.
Ja gut, aber das ist auch ein bisschen schwierig, für uns das mitzubekommen, weil es gab keinen deutschen Top-Verein, der nach einem Torhüter gesucht hat im Sommer. Daher hat man ja dann immer alle wichtigen Namen auf dem Zettel. Aber das gab es ja nicht. Deswegen würde ich die Schuld nicht bei uns suchen. Und Heungardt Son ist jetzt der neue Neuner. Sind Sie quasi von den Kane-Fesseln befreit? Warum habe ich denn die Überschrift überhaupt noch nicht gelesen?
Ich bin schon mehrfach gefragt worden, ob Tottenham jetzt ein besseres Team sei ohne Harry Kane. Zunächst hat er es mit Richard Leeson probiert, der aber glaube ich einfach in einem persönlichen Loch steckt. Auch von Konte hineingestoßen oder wenigstens nicht rausgezogen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so aktiv formulieren darf, aber wenigstens nicht rausgezogen, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Das hat aber nicht so funktioniert in den ersten Saisonspielen. Jetzt hat er Sonn auf die Neuen gestellt. Das funktioniert seither ganz gut. Um dem Ganzen auch noch eine Teil-Ernshaftigkeit zu geben, es ist schon so, dass Tottenham nach dem Kane-Transfer, mir war das zu jedem Zeitpunkt klar, ich glaube, das haben wir hier auch mal besprochen, oder wir haben es privat besprochen, aber mir war zu jedem Zeitpunkt klar, dass Tottenham den verkaufen würde. Weil es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, den jetzt ins letzte Vertragsjahr gehen zu lassen, wenn die Zeichen der Zeit ganz andere Dinge sagen. Und nachdem der Transfer durch war, hat Tottenham bei Social Media so sinngemäß gepostet, neue Zeitrechnung. Und genau das muss es auch sein, dass man allen Ernstes jetzt einfach den letzten Spieler, der noch übrig ist aus diesem Kern der 19. Finalmannschaft, der Champions League, also Son ist noch da, okay, und Loris theoretisch auch noch. Es schwirren noch zwei, drei andere rum, die aber keine große Rolle gespielt haben. Aber im Grunde genommen ist das jetzt in den USA, würde man sagen, der Rebuild ist final eingeleitet. Also der beste Spieler wurde gehen gelassen und da hat man Geld bekommen und jetzt baut man wirklich ernsthaft auf. Es ist jetzt der nächste Neuanfang sozusagen, aber mit einem Trainer, der wirklich auch dir anzeigt, dass es ein solcher ist. Also nicht heiter weiter und in der Volksspur bleiben, wie Mourinho, wie Conte oder wie keine Ahnung, was sie sich mit Nuno Espírito Santo dachten. Das wussten sie natürlich selber nicht. Jetzt ist es wirklich ein echter Neuanfang und den Geist des Ausbruchs, den spürt man gerade. Und das ist erstmal für mich deshalb, sind sie alleine als Positivbeispiel zu nennen, weil es überall, egal mit wem man spricht, einfach spür und hörbar ist. Die Fans sind glücklich über ein Team, das einfach gerne für die Spurs Fußball spielt. Mehr wollen die ja meistens gar nicht. Das ist ganz oft der Grundstein gewesen für erfolgreiche Zeiten da.
Ja, und als eins von vier ungeschlagenen Teams in der Premier League ist es dann nicht nur ein Rebuild, sondern aktuell auch ein Competitive Rebuild. Und das ist quasi der goldene Punkt. Da möchte man sein, wenn man schon im Rebuild ist. Aber damit genug der US-Sportanalogien ist ja hier nicht Downsett Talk. Wollen wir mal lieber auf die Serie A blicken. Und da gibt es verschiedene Themen. Ich weiß nicht, womit du beginnen möchtest. Christian, vielleicht schließt sich ein sogar gerade jetzt an.
Ja, fangen wir schon mal mit Neapel an. Da gab es ein bisschen emotionale Tage zuletzt. Also kurz zur Einordnung. Napoli hat am Wochenende in Bologna gespielt, hat 0-0 gespielt. Ist ja ein bisschen ergebnistechnisch, ist ein bisschen schwierig in die Saison gekommen. Viktor Osemen hat einen Elfmeter verschossen. Und danach wurde auf dem TikTok-Kanal von Napoli ein angebliches Video gepostet, das sich ein bisschen diesen verschossenen Elfmetern so ein bisschen vielleicht etwas lächerlich gemacht hat. Wobei man sagen muss, das gibt es zu anderen Napoli-Spielern auch solche Videos. Also es ist nicht das erste Mal. Fakt ist aber, dass Osemen und seine Unterage unfassbar ernst darauf reagiert haben. Der Berater hat gemeint, das ist eine Beleidigung für den Spieler. Sie drohen mit rechtlichen Konsequenzen. Osemen hat all seine Social-Media-Bilder mit Napoli gelöscht und es ist ja klar, dass da was anderes dahinter steckt. Das war jetzt das Bild dazu und logisch eine riesen Aufregung. Der Punkt ist der, da muss man im Sommer zurückgehen. Viktor Osemen war ja heiß um Wurmen, gar keine Frage, aus Europa und auch aus Saudi-Arabien, aber de Laurentis ist sehr standhaft geblieben, hat klar gemacht, dass er nicht abgibt und hat das auch bis Ende August durchgezogen. Aber es hing halt auch immer so eine Vertragsverlängerung dran. Da ging es logisch darum, dass Osemen sein Gehalt noch mal deutlich aufgebessert bekommt für das, was er ja auch an Leistung gezeigt hat, vergangenes Jahr und kurz vor Saisonstart hieß es, okay, der Vertrag ist mehr oder weniger durch. Eigentlich wartet der Laurentis nur noch drauf, so auf den großen Tag, um das groß zu verkünden. Aber die Verkündung hat er nicht stark gefunden. Also es gab keine Vertragsverlängerung und man hat von Anfang an, von ersten Spielen der Saison an, gemerkt, da schwingt so ein bisschen unterschwellig was mit. Da ist eine gewisse Nervosität dabei. Das fing schon an am ersten Spieltag. Da hat Napoli bei Frosinone beim Aufsteiger gewonnen und Rudi Garcia, der neue Trainer des Ballettennachfolges, hat danach Ossimen ein bisschen kritisiert für sein Spiel gegen den Ball. Also man hat gemerkt, das sind so ein paar Sachen, die wabern mit und die sind jetzt alle zum Tragen gekommen. Also jetzt muss man aber auch dazu sagen, wir zeichnen heute am Donnerstag auf. Gestrigen Mittwoch hat Napoli gespielt, sehr überzeugend 4-1 gewonnen zuhause gegen Udinese und Ossimen hat getroffen. Es war ja auch die Frage, wie würde er überhaupt spielen? Und da war schon klar, auch das ganze Publikum hat versucht, ihn wieder mitzunehmen. Auch die Teamkollegen hat man ganz genau gesehen. Er hat seine Arbeit gemacht, wie immer. Das muss man auch dazu sagen. Sowohl gegen Bologna als auch in der Champions League gegen Prager vergangene Woche, da hat er glaube ich zwei Postentreffer gehabt, gegen Bologna auch noch einen. Also da fehlt es im Moment auch ein bisschen im Spiegel, also du kannst ihm nichts vorwerfen, von wegen, dass er den Kopf hängen lässt. Aber dieser zaubernde Napoli, der in der vergangenen Saison inne hatte, war jetzt in den ersten Wochen ziemlich schnell verflogen. Und damit meine ich jetzt weniger das spielerische, als mehr so, was man so gespürt hat zwischen den Zeilen. Und das ist halt die riesen Aufgabe für Napoli, das irgendwie wieder auf die Spur zu bekommen. Denn es steckte immer noch wahnsinnig viel Qualität da. Quaratzkeli hat gestern zum ersten Mal wieder groß aufgezockt. Es sind ja noch alle da, bis auf Kim. Aber man hat so das Gefühl gehabt, oder das Gefühl ist immer noch ein bisschen richtig. Das Ballett, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Das ist ein Riesenfaktor. Das stellen sich manche vielleicht auch manchmal ein bisschen zu einfach vor. Das, okay, kommt einfach ein neuer Tränen und das läuft einfach so weiter. Nein, das ist klar, dass es nicht so ist. Aber es war eben, wie gesagt, da warbert es so ein bisschen was mit. Und dieser Ausbruch jetzt von Ozymen, der war jetzt sozusagen das heftigste Bild dazu. Mal schauen, was den nächsten Tagen, dem nächsten Spiel so passiert. Die kommende Woche kommt ja Real Madrid nach Neapel.
Und gegen Union wird man ja auch noch spielen. Findet ihr auch die Vorstellung so nett, dass da wirklich Ozymen sich in seinen Instagram-Account angelockt hat und dann alle Bilder gelöscht hat? Also, das ist wahrscheinlich eher jemand aus seinem Team.
Ja, da kann man logisch, was man da jetzt alles, was man da alles reininterpretieren will, ist ja ganz klar. Deswegen sagte ich ja, das war jetzt nur das Bild dazu. Da spielen ganz andere Sachen eine Rolle. Es ging ja auch immer darum, welche Klausel würde eventuell in seinen neuen Vertrag eingebaut werden. Napoli möchte die logisch so hoch wie möglich haben, ist ja klar, damit sie dann wieder in einer starken Position sind. Er selber, hieß es ihm, hat man immer so mitbekommen, ja gut, wenn die Klausel hoch sein muss, dann muss auch mein Gehalt noch höher sein. Ist ja auch klar. Und dementsprechend ist da einfach eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit da, die Gott sei Dank jetzt sportlich, wie gesagt, ich hatte Ozymenz, so wie ich ihn jetzt erlebt habe, nicht das Gefühl, dass er irgendwie weniger brennt, weil er kommt ja auch über seine Athletik, über seine Tiefenläufe, über dieses immer wieder attackieren und das war immer da. Und wie gesagt, er hat jetzt auch sehr viele Latten- und Pfostentreffer schon gehabt, also ist nicht so, dass der die Arbeit verweigert, gar keine Frage. Aber dieses unangenehme Gefühl, das Neapel halt so ein bisschen begleitet, es gab auch davor schon mal bei der Auswechslung in Bologna, da hat er so wild protestiert gegen die Bank. Quaratzkelia wurde schon mal runtergenommen, hat dann auch so eine Geste Richtung Bank gemacht. Also man spürt halt einfach, ja, wie gesagt, ich finde es am besten so beschrieben, der Zauber, der unter das Ballett, die da war, der ist halt, ich hatte gehofft, dass er vielleicht ein bisschen länger noch anhält oder zumindest noch Nuancen da sind. Der ist jetzt ziemlich schnell weggekommen, muss man sagen. Und das wird logisch eine große Aufgabe für Garcia, das Ganze zu moderieren.
Und gibt es irgendwelche Veränderungen jetzt zu Garcia hin?
Spielerisch? Ja, wenig. Also sie spielen nicht mehr so dominant, also nicht mehr so ballbesitzorientiert. Das sieht man sehr daran, dass Lobotka im Moment nicht mehr so ganz zentral ist. Also Lobotka war ja das, um den sich alles gedreht hat. Und jetzt unter Garcia spielen sie manchmal noch schon früher vertikaler, suchen noch früher die Tiefe, was logisch oseement zugute kommt, überspielen damit aber auch häufig Lobotka. Und das merkt man Lobotkan, auch Anguizá zum Beispiel, der ja immer so ein bisschen als Lobotka-Plus-Anguizá war ja auch immer, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass das Mittelfeld nicht nur spielerisch, sondern auch gegen den Ball sozusagen so stabil war. Dadurch, dass Lobotka im Moment nicht so zentral ist, merkst du auch, dass Anguizá im Moment nicht diese zentrale Rolle hat. Also man spürt schon, dass es Unterschiede gibt, klar. Und es ist irgendwie auch verständlich, dass Garcia versucht, kleine Akzente zu setzen. Aber, wie gesagt, ich glaube, mehr als taktischer Natur war es bisher wirklich das Problem, dass man halt einfach gespürt hat, da läuft nicht alles runter, da ist nicht alles im Umfeld oder im Mannschaftsumfeld so, wie es sein sollte. Ich fand es auch total beeindruckend, Giovanni Lorenzo, der Kapitän, der Rechtsverteidiger, über all den Zweifel erhaben, spielt wieder eine Bomben-Saison, ist so einfach der Stabilisator dieser Mannschaft. Er hat auch in Braga getroffen, bei diesem knappen Champions League-Auswärtssieg. Seine Geste war sofort, er hat alle mitgerufen, zur Bank gerufen, zum Jubeln. Auch der Kapitän versucht, diese mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit wirklich auch plakativ wiederherzustellen. Ich finde, das ist die große Aufgabe, die jetzt in Napoli da ist. Taktische Sachen kann man dann gerne besprechen. Wie gesagt, da gibt es Neuerungen. Auch Raspadouri hat eine zentralere Rolle, gar keine Frage. Aber erst mal geht es darum, dass Napoli so zueinanderfindet und dass sie dann immer noch so unfassbar viel Qualität haben. Wie gesagt, Quaratzkeli angesprochen, Ocimen, Politano funktioniert gut, Lorenzo spielt wieder großartig. Da ist ja sehr, sehr viel noch da und das gilt es jetzt eben wieder rauszukitzeln.
Aber das heißt, Garcia jetzt noch nicht umstritten. Ich will die Diskussion eh nicht aufmachen, aber ich fand schon eine interessante Trainerwahl, weil ich musste erst mal googeln, was der eigentlich so gemacht hat, dann habe ich gesehen, er war mal bei der Roma, aber das ist auch schon ewig her. 2015, 2016 gegangen und kam halt von Al Nasser. Die habe ich jetzt komischerweise nicht so im Blick gehabt, wie es da lief.
Du warst nicht der Einzige, der überrascht war. Definitiv. Das war eine ganz klare De Laurenti-Wahl. Er hat sich für ihn entschieden, hat damit auch viel überrascht. Garcia, weil du es an der Roma-Zeit angesprochen hast, ich glaube, er bringt viel Charakterstärke mit. Die wird er auch brauchen, weil es ist unruhig eben hier ab. Das merkt er jetzt. Das muss man vielleicht auch dazu sagen, kurz zur Einordnung. Das muss man vielleicht Garcia auch zugute kommen lassen. Ich glaube, jeder Trainer, der nach Spalletti da hingekommen wäre, hätte jetzt erst mal gewisse Probleme gehabt. Weil diese Wolke, auf der diese Mannschaft geschwebt ist und auch fußballerisch was sie gezeigt hat, dass das nicht einfach so weitergehen kann und dass du da in unfassbar große Fußstapfen reintrittst, das war klar für jeden Trainer. Und dann kam bei ihm jetzt halt auch noch dazu, dass er halt derjenige war, den nicht jeder auf dem Schirm gehabt hat. Ich finde, nach außen macht er es relativ ruhig. Er geht nicht auf Provokationen ein. Du merkst ihm an, dass er versucht, auch diese Ruhe auszustrahlen. Aber klar, er wird jetzt an den Ergebnissen gemessen. Napoli ist jetzt, da er ja hintergestern verloren hat, auch wieder in Schlagdistance. In der Champions League bin ich jetzt gespannt, was gegen Real passiert und so. Also die nächsten Spiele, er braucht halt einfach Ergebniskonstanz und die Hoffnung ist eben da, dass diese mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, das Schaffen, diese ganze OCM-Nummer und so alles sozusagen so einzufangen, dann bin ich fest davon überzeugt, wie gesagt, auch mit neuem Trainer, dass da immer noch unfassbar viel Qualität da ist.
Danke dir. Jetzt verstehe ich auch, warum diese OCM-TikTok-Geschichte so groß war. Weil ich mir nämlich gedacht habe, meine Güte, jetzt regt euch halt nicht alle auf. So was kommt halt mal vor. Aber jetzt verstehe ich, wenn man die ganze Backstory dazu erkennt, dann erklärt sich auch, warum es auch in deutschen Medien stattgefunden hat. Jetzt überlege ich gerade, wie Barca in den deutschen Medien stattgefunden hat. Das ist unser zweites Thema aus La Liga. Ich glaube vor allem dahingehend, dass Real sich Xavi Alonso schnappt. Das scheint er jetzt beschlossen, eine Sache zu sein. So schnell kann das gehen. Alex, wir hätten hier über den souveränen, ohne Punktverlust durchgestatteten, Tabellenführer Barca sprechen können, aber jetzt das zweite Unentschieden, also fast ohne Punktverlust gestartet, so ist es natürlich richtig, jetzt das zweite Unentschieden von Barca. Und dennoch lohnt es sich, mal drauf zu blicken, denn da läuft ziemlich viel, ziemlich gut, trotz dieses 2 zu 2s jetzt gegen Mallorca.
Ja, wie blickt Deutschland auf Barcelona? Ich glaube, wohlwollender als in den letzten Jahren, auch wenn es finanziell natürlich immer noch schwer ist. Aber sie haben ja den einen oder anderen Spieler geholt, der auch in Deutschland, glaube ich, ganz gut angesehen wird. Also Cancelo natürlich zu nennen, der bei den Bayern jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Aber man weiß, der Typ ist einfach Weltklasse auf Rechtsverteidiger. Und João Felix wurde von den Fesseln von Csolo Simeone befreit. Wenn wir schon vorhin bei den Fesseln waren, greife ich das gerne auf. Und dem zum Beispiel siehst du wirklich an, dass der wie befreit agiert. Er hat ja ein ganz, ganz bemerkenswertes Interview im Sommer gegeben. Ich träume von Barca. Barca ist schon immer mein Lieblingsverein. Ich will dahin. Und das war wie eine Bombe in der Medienlandschaft. Denn es gab keine Rumors zuvor. Also es war nicht so, dass Barca an ihm dran ist. Oder dass, ja, man wusste natürlich, er ist unglücklich bei Atletico. Und natürlich will Atletico irgendjemanden in den Verein finden, der ihn wegkauft. Und er wollte weg. Das war klar. Aber es waren nicht so wirklich, es waren nicht so die Gerüchte hin, dass er hier oder da hingehen könnte. Vor allem nicht zum FC Barcelona. Und diese Gerüchte hat er quasi ja ins Leben erst gerufen. Oder indem er mit diesem Satz, mit diesem Interview auf den Tisch gehauen hat. Ja, und wie es halt dann häufig so ist, der Spieler bekommt ja nicht selten seinen Wunsch. Und in dem Fall spielt er bei seinem Traumverein und ist jetzt wirklich ein bisschen wie ausgewechselt. Es sind natürlich noch Early Days. Das waren ja erst, ich glaube, vier oder drei Spiele für Barca. Aber du hast direkt gesehen, in einer offensiven Ballbesitzmannschaft, die mit Balldingen kreiert, ist er ein wirklich, wirklich toller Spieler und kann ein Asset sein für jede Mannschaft. Er war bei Atletico, hat er einfach nicht in das System gepasst, in diesen reaktionären, Scholo-Semione-Fußball. Wie Mauern kontern. Bei Chelsea war es eine, kann man das hier sagen, Shit-Show. Auf Englisch geht es, glaube ich, wenn man es sagt. Also da hat ja gar nichts funktioniert, da war er dann auch komplett verloren. Und jetzt beim FC Barcelona hat man das Gefühl, auch wenn es wie gesagt noch früh ist, dass er wirklich bei einem Verein ist, bei einer Fußballmannschaft, bei der er funktionieren kann. Das haben die ersten drei, viertagige Spiele gezeigt. Glaub ich schon, zwei Tore in der Champions League, eins in La Liga, jetzt am Wochenende in Mallorca, einen Pfostenschuss. Also ist schon, obwohl er noch erst vier Wochen gefühlt da ist, sehr, sehr gut eingebunden. Und Ähnliches gilt für Cancelo, nämlich auch. Dass der Weltklasse war, wusste man bei Man City. Da war er eher nicht zu verstehen, warum Pepin plötzlich los werden wollte. Und auch der ist jetzt bei einer Fußballmannschaft, bei der er sehr, sehr gut passt. Und nach drei, vier Spielen erinnert er wirklich erstmals seit Dekaden an jemanden, der wie Dani Alves spielt. Das ist ja das, was ich schon seit Jahren sage und was auch der Barcelonismus seit Jahren sagt. Barca braucht so einen Dani-Alves-Typen als Rechtsverteidiger, also einen offensiven Mann. Dribbelstark, kreativ, starke Flanken, technisch sehr, sehr versiert. Und auch er, Kanzler, hat jetzt, glaube ich, schon zwei Tore geschossen, ein oder zwei aufgelegt. Also einen richtig, richtig guten Start bei Barca. Und die beiden haben Barca so ein bisschen belebt, ja.
Das ist ja wirklich verrückt. Vor allem, ich habe gerade, als du das gesagt hast, Joao Felix und Ballbesitzmannschaft, da habe ich drüber nachgedacht. Und alle Szenen, die ich im Kopf hatte von Joao Felix, waren, er wird langgeschickt und läuft allein über 40 Meter auf dem Torhüter zu und vergibt dann die Chance oder macht die Chance. Aber ich glaube, das lag gar nicht an ihm, sondern an den Teams, in denen er gespielt hat, wo er halt wirklich nicht so eingebunden wurde.
Ja, also meine Warnung war, Athletico und Bayern Chelsea, dass er irgendwie im Verloren war. Er wollte Fußball spielen, hatte aber nicht die Mitspieler, hatte nicht das funktionierende Konstrukt, die funktionierende Mannschaft und war da vorne oft auf sich allein gestellt. Ab und zu neben Grießmann, ab und zu war Morat, da vor ihm oder neben ihm und dann hat er einen Mitspieler, aber so richtig. Klar, Athletico spielt nicht immer schlecht und in Heimspielen spielen sie auch offensiver, aber trotzdem hattest du immer das Gefühl, der ist so ein bisschen ein Fremdkörper, der würde gerne mal mehr machen mit Ball, mit der Mannschaft. Das passt aber nicht so. Er muss viel defensiv arbeiten und wird da immer nach der 60. schon ausgewechselt. War sehr, sehr häufig so bei Athletico. Da war er immer stinksauer, ohne dass er ein schlechtes Spiel gemacht hat. Aber er wurde nie grün mit Jolo Simeone und wurde ja wirklich aussortiert im Sommer und blüht jetzt in den drei, vier, fünf Spielen bei Barca wirklich richtig gehend auf bisher. Und bei Chelsea, das weiß Uli am allerbesten, da hat ja gar nichts funktioniert in der letzten Rückrunde. Also war es ja wurscht, wenn du da reinsetzt in diese Lampard-Mannschaft. Das war ja wirklich unter alles auch.
Ich finde gar nicht, dass er das so schlecht gemacht hat. Also ich habe das auch ein paar Mal dann so gesagt und dabei bleibe ich auch. Ich glaube, das ist so die Einschätzung, die du ja auch im Grunde schon getroffen hast. Das ist halt keine Ein-Mann-Offensive, der Typ. Ich glaube, dass das jemand ist, den muss man dazu stellen. Also man würde sagen Schattenstürmer oder das aber auch glaube ich gar nicht richtig, sondern aber im Grunde jemand, der in eine funktionierende Offensive dazukommt, die aufs nächste Level führt, aber nicht die Offensive selbst ist. Und das war glaube ich das Problem bei Chelsea, respektive es gab halt gar keine, weil es Frank Lampard war und niemand anderes. Aber so schlecht war das gar nicht.
Und weil zehn Spieler gekauft wurden, die sich teilweise nicht mehr kannten.
Ja, und auch das ist ja fast polemisch, das sozusagen. Da kamen viele Spieler auf einmal dazu, also viele, viele Deals einfach nur, die da gemacht werden und wurden. Und das ist ja nach wie vor noch so, dass einfach der, es ist nicht Todd Bolli im Übrigen, der das Sagen hat, sondern Peter Degbali mit Clear Lake Capital, der deutlich mehr meldet. Und das ist ja immer noch jemand, der einfach jetzt schon wieder auf der Suche nach dem nächsten Deal ist, einfach nur weil er langweilig ist. Und er möchte halt Deals machen. Und die kommen aber wiederum aus der Phase, als Chelsea noch eingefroren war. Und da ist einfach, glaube ich, so viel passiert in den letzten zwei Jahren. Das kann man gar nicht alles erklären und erzählen, wie schwierig das für alle ist, sich der ganzen Sache immer wieder anpassen zu müssen. Ich finde aber dafür hat es Felix eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht gemacht, sondern er hat halt kein Tor erzielt, er hat halt nie getroffen. Das war das große Problem. Aber der grundsätzliche Output war nicht so verkehrt. Er war noch mit der Beste, finde ich.
In einer sehr unterirdischen Mannschaft.
Genau, in der Truppe, wo halt einfach, oder in einem Verein, das ist ja das rasante Tempo, der Neuaufbauten, das ist ja alles gar nicht.
Auf jeden Fall jetzt bei Barca funktioniert er wirklich gut und sehr, sehr interessant. Am meisten profitiert eigentlich Robert Lewandowski von seinen zwei neuen Mitspielern, also beiden Portugiesen, der sich auch in der letzten Rückrunde sehr, sehr schwer getan hat, ins Szene gesetzt zu werden, weil er nicht so die Mitspieler hat. Xavi hat auch immer wieder auf so ein Vierermittelfeld umgestellt, wo einfach die beiden Außenbahn-Spieler teilweise fehlten. Oft hat so Gavi so eine Hybridrolle gespielt. Und jetzt hat er wirklich einen Mitspieler, im fast schon wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, der mit ihm Fußball spielt, der ihn füttert. Exemplarisch dafür war, glaube ich, ein Lupfer gegen Celta Vigo von João Felix. Den machen keine zehn anderen Spieler auf der Welt diesen Pass. Den siehst du gar nicht. Und er lupft ihn so in den Lauf von Lewandowski und er überlupft den Torwart. Und Cancelo hat, glaube ich, auch wieder direkt ihm ein Tor aufgelegt. Also Lewandowski ist tatsächlich der große Profiteur von den beiden Portugiesen bei Barca. Und die ganze Offensivmaschinerie funktioniert jetzt wesentlich besser als zuvor. Zwei 5-0-Siege gab es. Aber ja, eben auch diesen unerwarteten Ausrutscher auf Mallorca, wo sie sich wirklich sehr, sehr schwer getan haben. Also da sieht man, alles ist noch nicht rosig.
Aber das heißt, spielt jetzt Scharvi gar nicht mehr mit diesem Dreieraufbau aus einer Viererkette, wo Gavi einrückt und so quasi aufgefüllt wird, das Mittelfeld? Oder macht er das jetzt?
Also aktuell wird ein bisschen auch roschiert, sowohl von der Taktik, sowohl von der Aufstellung her, weil er natürlich jetzt mit Felix, den setzt er meist auf dem linken Flügel, wobei er, wie Uli schon gesagt hat, er einrückt. Also er agiert dann oft in diesen halben Zehnerraum, halben linken Zehnerraum und rückt da ein, sodass bald D hinterlaufen kann, der Linksverteidiger, der ja unfassbar schnell ist und auch eine starke Debüt-Saison letztes Jahr hatte. Das funktioniert sehr, sehr gut, wenn Felix da einrückt, für die Mannschaft und auch generell für die einzelnen Spieler. Und auf rechts rotiert zum Beispiel durch. Jetzt hat er auf Mallorca, glaube ich zur Halbzeit, als so gar nichts ging, hat er sehr, sehr interessant, hat auf Dreierkette umgestellt und hat Cancelo auf die rechte Sechs gestellt. Also der war wirklich zentraler Mittelfeldspieler, weil er das eben so unglaublich gut kann. Also auch mit Ball. Den kannst du ja fast jede Position spielen lassen, außer vielleicht Stürmer. Wobei er auch ein Mittelstürmer-Tor geschossen hat gegen Celta Vigo.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Alex, also dieses Tor gegen Celta, wo sie es gedreht haben, also mal anschauen, dieses Einlauf-Verhalten von Cancelo, unfassbar. Also wirklich fast, ja, das kannst du mittelstürmen.
Das heißt, ihr wollt mir jetzt gerade erzählen, Cancelo spielt alle Positionen, die der FC Bayern gesucht hat, dieses Sommer. Habt ihr mir das gerade erzählen wollen? Außenverteidiger, Sechs und Stürmer.
In einer Person.
Hält er auch noch die Sechs? Kann er auch noch eine Holding-Six?
Nein, aber Cancelo ist wirklich, finde ich, der Real Deal mit Ball. Ohne Ball, weiß man, muss man gucken, wenn die großen Gegner kommen. Die kamen ja bisher auch nicht, gehört ja auch zur Wahrheit dazu. Barca hat jetzt weder Atletico noch, keine Ahnung, Real Bayern, wie sie alle heißen, hatten sie auch noch nicht. Kommt ja erst noch. Aber gegen die normalen Gegner in der Liga ist Cancelo so ein unfassbares Upgrade auf rechts, weil er wirklich zwei, drei Positionen gleichzeitig spielt. Also der ist rechts außen, der ist rechter Mittelfeldspieler, der ist rechtsverteidiger. Wenn er einrückt, ist er rechter Achter und fühlt sich da wohl und spielt mit Selbstvertrauen.
Aber warte mal auf, wenn es mal nicht läuft. Also es gibt ja schon wirklich Gründe bei City, warum Guardiola den rechts stellt. Also es war ja tatsächlich überraschend, aber binnen zwei Wochen rauskomplimentiert hat, kam nach der WM zurück, hatte keine Form. Dann hat Guardiola irgendwann mal vor Ort gesagt, vielleicht liegt es ja an frischen Gründen. Und dann musste er dermaßen gestänkert haben und teilweise wirklich vier, fünf, sechs Leute in der Kabine so angezündet haben, teilweise auch überredet haben, lass uns zusammen weggehen, dass Guardiola irgendwann gesagt hat, okay, das funktioniert so nicht, hat ihm wohl eine deutliche Ansage gemacht. Und daraufhin hat Vakanzelo total beleidigt und wollte gehen. Und das weiß man ja bei Guardiola, also mit der einen Ausnahme Bernardo Silva, wenn jemand gehen möchte, dann hält er den nicht auf. Und das muss aber wirklich ein Ausmaß angenommen haben. Das war ganz, ganz schwierig. Vakanzelo hat ja teils dessen, glaube ich, auch eingeräumt, dann in einem Interview mit einer portugiesischen Zeitung, dass er impulsiv ist und dass er durchaus, wenn er an einem dunklen Platz ist, dann ist er an einem dunklen Platz. Und so. Ich habe es auch aus München vernommen. Der kam an und war nicht beliebt von vornherein. Deswegen habe ich dann schon verstanden, dass man relativ schnell die Finger davon gelassen hat. Mich hat es eher gewundert, dass man dann gegen Ende des Fensters doch noch mal fast hingesprungen wäre, wenn das stimmt. Aber der muss sich bei City wirklich Dinge geleistet haben. Das ist erstaunlich.
Da muss man natürlich abwarten, wie es dann ist, wenn er nicht so viel spielt oder wenn es nicht so gut läuft. Interessanterweise hat er sich jetzt sehr, sehr selbstkritisch gegeben nach dem 2-3 gegen Celta. Da hat, glaube ich, dein Kollege –ich weiß nicht, wer es kommentiert hat –der Sohn-Kommentator hätte ihn schon drei Mal ausgewechselt, wäre des Spiels, weil er wirklich schwach war. Und immer wieder haben die Kollegen gesagt, jetzt muss Cancelo eigentlich raus. Der ist einer der Schwächsten. Er blieb aber drauf und machte das Siegtor in der 90. Also alles richtig gemacht von Schafis Sicht. Und sehr interessant danach stellt er sich ans Mikrofon und sagt, ich habe ein richtig, richtig schlechtes Spiel gemacht. Und er ist ja nur ausgeliehen und hat gesagt, ich muss einfach gute Leistung zeigen, damit die mich verpflichten, wenn ich das nicht tue. Also sehr, sehr selbstkritisch, sehr, sehr geerdet. Auch ein bisschen ungewöhnlich, dass er das so formuliert. Aber ich fand das sehr, sehr interessant, dass er da wirklich selbstkritisch sagt, das war wirklich ein schlechtes Spiel von mir und ich muss mich da definitiv verbessern. Und ja, das eint ihn ein bisschen mit Felix, dass beide da wirklich sein wollen. Ich glaube, das setzt schon so ein paar Leistungsprozentpunkte nochmal frei, dass sie da wirklich unbedingt zum FC Barcelona hinwollten, da unbedingt sein wollen und da jetzt wirklich Gas geben. Und das siehst du allein am Torjubel von Cancelo. Du meinst, das ist der Siegtreffer im Halbfinale der WM für Portugal. So hat er gejubelt. Also da merkst du schon, die haben schon richtig Bock. Das ist für die ein neuer Start und eine neue Chance bei diesem Verein.
Wir sind schon so lange im Basler Segment und trotzdem muss ich jetzt noch eine Frage stellen. Denn eine Sache haut mich um. Also zum einen, wir haben jetzt noch gar nicht über Ilkay Gündo angesprochen. Das war ja wahrscheinlich der andere Wechsel, den wir mitverfolgt haben, den du vorhin auf den du vorhin angespielt hast, der ja eher Achter spielt als Sechser, also vorgezogen. Und dann denkt man sich, naja, auf der Sechshalte Jong ist ja klar, ja, nix gibt's. Da steht Oriol Romeo von Girona gewechselt. Der ist 32, nee 31 Jahre alt. Ich hab's extra gerade noch nachgeguckt. Hab's natürlich prompt gleich wieder vergessen. 32 Jahre alt, ist von Girona gekommen und der ist jetzt der neue Denker und Lenker im Mittelfeld von Barca?
Übrigens richtig interessant, weil du die Bayern angesprochen hast. Den hätte Tuchel sich schnappen können, schnappen sollen vielleicht sogar oder besser gesagt, die Bayern wollten ja diese Holding Six und das ist wirklich eine typische Holding Six. Also so ein ganz, ganz klassischer Sechser, ganz alter Schule, fast schon aus den 90ern, der wirklich abräumt, der die Abwehrkette beschützt, der Zweikämpfe bestreitet und gewinnt, der Gretchen auspackt und der ansonsten ganz, ganz wenig macht. Also über der Mittellinie siehst du den kaum. Klar, bei Barca, die spielen immer weiter vorne und dann macht er ein paar Querpässe, aber sein einziger Job ist wirklich, die Abwehrreihe zu beschützen. Also eine Holding Six, wie sie im Buche steht, der kam, glaube ich, für drei Millionen. Man muss aber natürlich dazu sagen, er hat sogar auf Geld verzichtet, aber Barca ist sein Jugendverein. Also der war in der Jugend dann, in La Masia war dann irgendwann nicht gut genug, wie so viele La Masia-Talente und ging dann über drei, vier Umwege, ich glaube, ging ja erst zu Chelsea und dann Stuttgart. Vielleicht habe ich eine Station vergessen. Stimmt, stimmt, na klar. Da ist er mir übrigens damals, und das fand ich so kurios, warum er ihn in Barca jetzt geholt hat, auch da ist er mir nie positiv aufgefallen. Also weder bei Southampton noch bei Stuttgart. Ich hätte nie im Leben gedacht, der hat das Zeug dazu, mal bei Barca wiederzulanden. Und der ist ja wirklich sogar Stammspieler. Weil Xavi gemerkt hat, Busquets ist ja weg, das heißt, sie brauchte einen neuen Sechser, sie hatten kein Geld, brauchten also eine günstige Option. Und haben dann ihn zurückgeholt, damit er wirklich diesen einen Job macht, und zwar aufräumen, grätschen, Bälle erobern, that's it. Und Xavi hat das jetzt so gemacht, dass er fast schon mit einer Doppel-Sex teilweise gespielt hat und hat Frankie de Jong auf die andere Sex. Und das ist ja die Lieblingsrolle von Frankie de Jong. Man kennt es ja auch von der holländischen Nationalmannschaft, die Doppel-Sex mit einer Holding-Sex und mit der anderen quasi Free-Roaming-Sex. Frankie de Jong ist die beste Wunschposition von Frankie de Jong. Und jetzt ist er aktuell leider verletzt, aber das war so die Umstellung zu dieser neuen Saison von Xavi.
Uli hat schon zweimal Luft geholt, weil er irgendwas sagen wollte. Du hast ihn ja gesehen.
Ich finde den Begriff Holding-Sex so geil, den gibt es halt gar nicht.
Ja, das ist natürlich alles Pratsch, wir verwenden den ironisch, oder? Da sind wir uns einig.
Ich hoffe doch. Deswegen finde ich das immer so lustig, weil in England sagen die immer, was redet der, wenn man quatscht.
Du bist ein Goalgetter. Wenn du das im englischsprachigen Bereich sagst, da weisen die dich direkt ein.
Ich greife nur diesen Begriff auf, der durch die Medienlandschaft flattert seit Wochen und Monaten.
Man weiß ja auch, was gemeint ist. Deswegen passt es ja schon. Ich verstehe schon, was gemeint ist mit Holding-Sex. Aber in England gab es zwei Kollegen, die mich angeschrieben hatten und gesagt haben, was genau will der Thomas Tuchel mit diesem Holding-Sex sein? Kannst du mir das mal ernsthaft erklären? Dann habe ich versucht zu sagen, ich tippe mal, man muss es sich Anker-Sexer oder Defensiv-Sexer nennen oder so was. Oder absichernder Sexer, keine Ahnung. Aber ich weiß bis heute auch nicht, dass auch ein Versäumnis von uns allen, dass Tuchel nie gefragt worden ist, was meinst du denn damit? Also wer wäre denn der ideale Spielertyp? Ich glaube, ich nehme nach wie vor nicht, dass es der zerstörende Defensiv-Sexer wäre. Aber das führt jetzt viel zu weit weg.
Wahrscheinlich hat sich keiner getraut, das zu fragen. Weil er von der Holding Six gesprochen hat und alle so Holding Six noch nie gehört. Was zum Teufel soll das sein? Na ja, wahrscheinlich irgendeine Art der Sex. Eine Defensiv-Sex. Und dann traut sich keiner. Und in Woche 2, wo schon alle darüber gesprochen haben, das sind die Optionen für die Holding Six. Und deshalb braucht Bayern keine Holding Six. Dann traust du dich nicht mehr zu fragen, Herr Tuchel, wie haben sie das denn eigentlich gemeint?
Genau, können Sie mir mal das Profil erklären? Ich habe es dann über Umwege erfahren, was das Profil ist. Also quasi aus seinem Umfeld, aber nicht von ihm. Aber öffentlich ging es dann einfach wie ein Treppenwitz.
Ich glaube, Prototyp für diese Position, für diesen Begriff ist wahrscheinlich Rodri, im Weltfußball, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Ich glaube, Jorginho, so wie ich das verstanden habe. Also noch Pass, Automatik.
Also der neue, also Xavi Alonso in der heutigen Zeit.
Genau, der Liverpool Thiago. Also jetzt geht es wieder, der Wettbewerb wird vielleicht frei, Thiago. Ja, aber so in die Richtung, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, hätte es gehen sollen.
Moment mal, warum wird Thiago wieder frei?
Ich weiß nicht, warum bei Thiago gerade Dinge nicht laufen, aber Vertrag läuft ja aus und er ist seit Ewigkeiten mit einer kleinen Verletzung raus und niemand weiß genau, was los ist bei dem. Also es ist ein totales Mysterium, warum Frau niemand mehr von ihm spricht bei Liverpool.
Na gut, das hat ja dann oft Gründe. Wenn es kleine Verletzungen gibt, niemand davon spricht, dann gibt es dafür oft Gründe, die aber dann halt einfach niemandem was angehen und deswegen dann auch nicht…
Wobei da Liverpool eigentlich… Genau, aber da gibt es bei Liverpool dann eigentlich meistens schon Termini dafür, dass man das dann weiß, dass man jetzt auch bitte nicht mehr nachfragen soll. So, da wird es wirklich so, dass man immer sagt, er ist jetzt noch ein paar Wochen entfernt, aber dann kommt er wieder und das wird dann seltsam. Tatsächlich, so dass ich irgendwie auch glaube, da ist irgendwas im Busch, aber ich kann es nicht umdrehen. Sie bräuchten ihn eigentlich zahlenmäßig, daher ist es auch seltsam.
Okay, ich dachte schon, er wäre von Endo verdrängt worden. Das wäre nämlich dann… Dann hätten wir das zweite Premier League-Thema nämlich über einen Haufen werfen müssen.
Meine Frage ist, ist Endo eine Holding Six?
Ich glaube, von der Positionierung her ja, aber vom Profil her nicht. Na ja, er lässt sich schon fallen.
Aber er ist so ein klassischer Box-to-Box. Gebt ihm den Ball und da muss ihm erst mal abtrennen, dass er nicht immer gleich losdrüben wird.
Aber ich glaube nicht bei Kloppo.
Ja, klar, da muss es ja auch nicht.
Also, was ich jetzt gesehen hatte, war er eher schon derjenige, der geschickt hat.
Okay, ach, es ist so schön, der Fußball. Oriol Romeo, das hätte ich nie gedacht. Er hat null mitbekommen, diesen kompletten Wechsel. Aber deswegen machen wir ja die Ligatur, dass ich meine Wissenslücken füllen kann. Und dann sind es nämlich oft auch die Lücken der Hörerinnen und Hörer nicht immer natürlich. Es gibt immer Leute da draußen, die wissen mehr. Und die wüssten jetzt zum Beispiel auch, Uli alles zu Sheffield United zu erzählen.
Wer weiß das nicht.
Ja, wer weiß das nicht. Aber wiederhol doch noch mal für uns alle, die vielleicht nicht aufgepasst haben in der letzten Schulstunde. Was müssen wir denn zu denen wissen?
Also eigentlich ist ganz einfach 0 zu 8 verloren am Wochenende. Und damit weiß man schon, dass es da nicht so gut aussieht. Das ist tatsächlich eine Niederlage, die die seltenen Trainer überleben, wenn dann aber in der Premier League, wie wir es gelernt haben. Ralf-Hasen Hüttele hat es ja gleich zweimal mit einem Tor mehr sogar geschafft. Mich hat es trotzdem gewundert. Mein Tipp für die erste Trainerentlassung in England war ohnehin Paul Hackingbottom. Ich dachte dann auch schon die Woche vor dem 8-0, dass ich Recht hatte, weil Gerüchte aufkamen, dass Chris Wilder wieder parat stünde. Das wäre derjenige, der Sheffield zunächst wieder in die Premier League gebracht hat, nachdem sie ja schon bis in die Dritte Liga abgestürzt waren. Der ist eigentlich nur gegangen bei Sheffield. Das weiß man inzwischen, weil er sich gestritten hat mit dem Scheich Prinz Abdullah. Der vorher über ihn erzählt hat, es wird sein neuer Alex Ferguson. Dann haben sie sich gestritten, dann ist er gegangen, ist dann über zwei verschiedene Umwege, Stationen, wäre dann wieder parat gewesen. Jetzt ist aber tatsächlich das passiert, dass Hacking Bottom das Vertrauen ausgesprochen bekommen hat, immer noch im Amt ist, was einen einerseits wundert und andererseits, aber mich auch vor allen Dingen zur Frage führt, würde das überhaupt großartig was verändern bei Sheffield, wenn ein neuer Trainer da wäre? Das ist die große Frage. So viel ist im Sommer los gewesen. Im März gab es schon Gerüchte, dass sie eigentlich in England, sagt man ja, into administration, also in die Insolvenz gehen müssen, Punkt eins. Dann war aber relativ klar, sie würden Transfersperre bekommen, also ein Embargo, dass sie zwei Transferperioden nicht mehr transferieren dürften, würden sie nicht aufsteigen. Jetzt sind sie aber aufgestiegen, das heißt, das wurde aufgehoben. Trotzdem war die erste Amtshandlung gleich mal den besten Offensivspieler der vergangenen Saison zu verkaufen, Elimon Djaï zu Marseille. Und dann kurz vor Ende der Transferperiode auch noch den besten Defensivspieler in Sanderberge, zu verkaufen. Logischerweise ersatzlos. Also da möchte man trotzdem Geld verdienen. Es gibt Fans, die spekulieren –und so dumm ist das gar nicht –,dass Sheffield überhaupt gar kein Interesse drin hat, in der Liga zu bleiben, sondern erst mal nur, sich zu stabilisieren im Umfeld der Premier League und die falschen Zahlungen mal auf jeden Fall sicher mit dazu zu bekommen. Das heißt, in England, wenn man heruntergeht, kriegt man drei Jahre lang Gelder, um den Absturz aus der viel und groß bezahlten Premier League überhaupt einigermaßen durchstehen zu können mit logischerweise aufgepumptem Kader etc. Und da gibt es Spekulationen drüber. Ich habe am Anfang gedacht, was soll das für ein Käse sein? Also, damit kann man ja niemals spekulieren, aber vielleicht ist es gar nicht so doof. Also, kurzum, der Verein war ein totales Chaos im Frühjahr. Dann kam der sportliche Erfolg dazu, der Aufstieg in die Premier League. Und jetzt ist der sportliche Chaos, aber zumindest finanziell einigermaßen gedeckelt. Und da sind wir jetzt im Moment an der Stelle.
Und kann es sein, dass Sheffield United seine Trainer nur danach aussucht, wie geil der Name klickt? Weil sowohl Chris Wilder als auch Paul Hackingbottom –das ist ja sensationell.
Hacking, ja, er stimmt, er ist eigentlich ein Trainer, von dem ich –ich könnte dir jetzt nichts Positives sagen. Tatsächlich in der ganzen Zeit. Er muss irgendwie irgendetwas haben, das kann ich von vorherigen Stationen nicht bestätigen. Aber er muss irgendwas gemacht haben, mit dem Umfeld, dass die Truppe überdurchschnittlich gut zusammengehalten hat, trotz dieser ganzen Sachen. Und vielleicht war es einfach nur die Belustigung über den Namen in der Kabine. Vielleicht hat er den einfach nur laut gesagt und dann war Alex sagt, yes.
Ich komme da den besten Punkteschnitt, wenn man irgendwelche Trainer aus dem 19. Jahrhundert, David Stiel, herzliche Grüße an der Stelle. Ein Spiel hat er gewonnen, 1934. War trotzdem von 1934 bis 1936 Trainer. Okay, vielleicht ist da die Datenbank nicht komplett. Aber wenn man ganz alte Trainer mit rausnimmt und vielleicht noch Danny Wilson, der zwischen 2011 und 2013 mit dabei war, besten Punkteschnitt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, woher hier deine Kritik kommt.
Es ist erstaunlich, als die den damals ins Amt nahmen. Man kam ja von Chris Wilder und man hatte irgendwie das Gefühl, die sind fast etabliert in der Premier League. Das ist ein großes Wort, aber das war schon okay, wie sie es gemacht haben. Und dann holt die Paul Hackenbottom. Die letzten Male, als ich irgendwo gearbeitet habe, war das immer so ein Feuerwehrmann, ohne im Tabellenkeller zu stehen. Da habe ich mich gewundert, was sie eigentlich mit dem wollen. Ich mache das immer ganz gerne, auch in unserem Podcast, Premier League, dass ich sage, es gibt Trainer, die verändern dir was zu Positiven hin. Und es gibt Trainer, die machen keinen Unterschied. Und er war bei mir fast sogar im Segment drunter, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, der macht die eher schwächer. Weil das Team, der Kader ist nicht gut, ist wahrscheinlich auch mit Absolutnis noch schwächer. Aber die haben zum Beispiel einen Trainer an der Seitenlinie, wo ich denke, der verändert was zum Positiven hin, weil der sehr viel aggressiver spielen lässt. Und das ist, die Zahlen in der Premier League in den letzten wenigstens zwei Saisonen, soweit habe ich es jetzt nachgeguckt, zeigen, dass die Teams, die mit dem wenigsten aktiven Pressing agieren, auch die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, abzusteigen. In der letzten Saison waren es ausschließlich die Teams, die passivsten sind abgestiegen am Ende. Trotz Qualität, also wir reden nicht über Qualität, sondern nur mal grundsätzlich der Fakt, sind sie aggressiv vorne drauf oder nicht. Und in dem Fall haben wir wieder einen Trainer, von dem ich denke, das ist nicht das Richtige.
Ja, okay, das klingt schon sehr eindeutig so, das muss man tatsächlich zugeben. Also wir werden verfolgen, was Paul Hackingbottom bei Sheffield United macht. Das ist ein wunderschöner Satz, das tue ich leider. Also da komme ich nicht drüber hinweg. Aber von solchen Oberflächlichkeiten wollen wir natürlich jetzt nichts wissen, wenn wir über Sassuolo noch sprechen. Denn das haben vielleicht sogar manche Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen, die haben zuletzt ganz schön für Aussehen gesorgt in der Serie A, Christian. Und das hängt jetzt nicht primär mit dem 8. Tabellenplatz zusammen, den sie haben, und 9 Punkten aus 6 Spielen, sondern ich glaube mit 6 Punkten, die man aus den letzten zwei Spielen geholt hat.
Ja, genau, Sassuolo hat wieder mal das gemacht, was sie am liebsten machen. Wenn sie erst gegen Frosinone 4-2 verlieren, gegen Aufsteige, wo du denkst, was ist mit denen wieder los, dann schlagen sie Juve 4-2 und drei Tage später, sprich gestern gewinnen sie Insan Siro gegen Inter nach Rückstand 2-1. Zur Einordnung, Inter hat bisher alle fünf Spiele souverän gewonnen, war ganz klar die Benchmark der Liga. Und ja, Sassuolo macht halt wieder mal Sassuolo-Dinge. Also es ist echt faszinierend, wie gesagt, innerhalb von drei Tagen Juve und Inter schlagen, ist jetzt nicht ganz ohne. Wenn es aber eine Mannschaft in Italien kann, dann ist das genau Sassuolo. Also da gibt es Statistiken dazu, die glaubst du fast nicht. Also ich habe es mir herausgesucht. Dionisi, der Trainer, der jetzt schon seit ein paar Jahren da ist, der hat seit er bei Sassuolo ist, war fünfmal in San Siro zu Gast, also bei Milan und Inter, und hat vier Spiele davon gewonnen. Die haben heuer im Januar sind sie zu Milan und haben da 5-2 gewonnen. Klar, da muss man sagen, da war Milan diese schwierige Phase, wo nichts zusammen lief. Aber trotzdem, du musst erst mal in San Siro rein und solche Leistungen bringen. In der vergangenen Saison haben sie in Rom bei der Roma 4-3 gewonnen. Gegen Mourinho vier Puden machen, wissen wir alle auch nicht ganz so einfach. Also es ist eine Spektakelmannschaft, die auf höchstem Niveau die Konstanz vermissen lässt. Deswegen sind sie auch in den letzten Jahren, haben sie es nie geschafft, sich europäisch zu qualifizieren, weil sie dann eben diese Frosinone-Spiele drin haben und so, weil eben diese Ergebniskontinuität fehlt. Aber sobald da das Flutlicht angeht und irgendwie große Gegner da sind, große Stadien, dann sind die immer gefährlich. Und das war gestern. Also gegen Inter muss man echt sagen, also Inter macht kurz vor der Halbzeit das 1-0, dann freest, und dann denkst du dir, wow, okay, Inter bisher alle Spiele gewonnen, wirken unfassbar stabil, was soll da noch groß gehen? Und dann kommt die zweite Hälfte, und dann fangen die an, Inter phasenweise, muss man echt sagen, zu dominieren, weil das eine spielstarke Mannschaft ist. Und ich kann es nur jedem raten, schaut euch das 2-1 von Berardi an. Also, krasses Traumtor, so ein Robin-Move, wo er eben von rechts kommt, genau sein Move. Erst wackelt der Miki Darin, glaube ich, 3-4 Mal aus, und dann setzt er den Ball mit links vom rechten Strafe, vom eng ins lange Eck, unten, Sommer, keine Chance. Also, das 1-1 hat er vor.
Weil er natürlich zu klein ist.
Absolut, ja, genau. Und Berardi hat auch schon gegen Jube drei Tage davor getroffen, mit einem ähnlichen Move, wieder mit links von der Strafe um den Gänse da unten rein. Das ist so ein bisschen sein Signature-Move. Und Berardi ist halt auch, da kommen wir vielleicht dann später dazu, wir haben noch den MVP, da möchte ich, nehmen wir da noch zwei, drei Sachen dazu. Aber das ist eben die Mannschaft, du hast Berardi vorder drin, du hast Lorientet, diesen auf der Gegenseite, auf linksen starken 1 gegen 1-Spieler, oder richtig starken 1 gegen 1-Spieler. Du hast mit Binamonti einen jungen italienischen Stürmer, wo alle jetzt darauf warten, dass er eben endlich sozusagen das Potenzial, das ihm nachgesagt wird, auch aufs Feld bringt. Das scheint jetzt in der Saison da zu sein. Er kam hier von Inter vor zwei, drei Jahren, hat jetzt viermal getroffen, auch schon in dieser Saison. Also ein Mittelstürmer-Typ, so ein bisschen Skamaka-mäßig, ein großer, körperlicher, der dann wunderbar eben dazu passt, dass auf Außen da diese dribbelstarken 1 gegen 1-Spieler sind. Also ist das Volo echt immer ein Hingehucker wert. Und wie gesagt, nochmal in drei Tagen Inter und Juve zu schlagen, das gelingt in Italien nicht vielen. Ja, also Berardi, wie gesagt, kommen wir später vielleicht noch. Also Berardi ist echt ein Phänomen. Also Berardi, Gaby, machen wir es doch gleich. Überraschenderweise ist Berardi der MVP. Damit konnte jetzt wirklich niemand rechnen. Da muss man auch ganz kurz in den Sommer nochmal zurückgehen. Berardi hat die ersten zwei Spiele verpasst. Und zwar nicht, weil er verletzt war oder so, sondern weil er rausgezogen wurde, weil es Verhandlungen mit Juve gab. Juve hat im Sommer wieder rangepackert an Berardi. Das ist ja die Geschichte, die sich schon über viele Jahre hinzieht, dass viele sagen, Berardi ist zu gut fürs Asvoller. Berardi sollte doch auch mal Champions League spielen oder so. Und die letzten Jahre hat er immer gesagt, ja, ich fühle mich total wohl in Asvoller. Da war vielleicht nie das richtige Angebot dabei. Aber das hat man so das Gefühl, okay, der bleibt jetzt da. Aber diesen Sommer hat er auch so zwischen den Zeiten zu verstehen gegeben, er würde jetzt schon ganz gerne nochmal quasi. Und dann ist Juve auch kurz vor knapp ums Eck gekommen. Aber das zeichnet Asvoller aus. Die haben dann gesagt, hey, liebe Leute, so läuft es nicht. Ihr könnt euch nicht fünf Tage vor Transferschluss melden. Und dann auch nicht zu den Konditionen, die wir halt gerne hätten. Die haben da ein Preisschild ausgehangen, das bei Asvoller immer relativ teuer ist. Sie haben ja einen Inter abgegeben, aber sie geben ja immer wieder Spiele ab. Aber sie kassieren dann auch ganz ordentlich dafür. Und am Ende hat sich Asvoller durchgesagt und gesagt, nee, so kurz vor Schluss gehen wir nicht mehr ab. Schluss. Und dann war Bernhard eben, wie gesagt, die ersten zwei Spiele nicht im Kader. Er hat abseits der Mannschaft auch simple fit gehalten. Und jetzt ist er wieder da. Und er ist wirklich die Seele dieser Mannschaft und ein unfassbar guter Kicker. Also in diesem System und bei Sassuolo, wenn du Berardi siehst, sobald es Richtung Strafraum geht, ist da immer Torgefahr, wenn er mit dabei ist. Sei es eben durch diesen Abschluss, sei es durch diesen Steckpass, den er bei Mainz 1 spielt. Klar, das sieht Sommer am Kurzen Pfosten nicht gut aus, aber den Ball da reinspielen Richtung Bayrami, den spielen auch nicht so viele. Also Berardi irgendwie scheint er mit Sassuolo verheiratet zu sein, auch wenn in diesem Sommer es anders ausgesehen hat. Alex hat es ja gesagt, also die Zahlen sprechen für ihn. Der ist viel mehr als der Starspieler dieser Mannschaft, der trägt diese Mannschaft auch. Irgendwie wäre ich wirklich auch noch gespannt, weil er ist jetzt auch nicht mehr der Jüngste. Ich wäre schon auch gespannt, ihn nochmal bei einem Top-Club zu sehen. Deswegen, Allegri wollte ihn unbedingt, hätte gerne dann eben Käser links, Berardi rechts, da auch so diese italienische Nationalmannschaftsflügelsange gehabt. Mal schauen, ob im Winter vielleicht Juba nochmal ein bisschen ranbaggert. Das Ding ist ja nicht final durch, aber eben, wie gesagt, seine Leistungen in der Liga und wie er Sausuolo wirklich mitreißt und was er da ausbaggt. Also nochmal, wer es nicht gesehen hat, schaut euch das Tor an. Und das ist was, das baggt Berardi immer wieder aus. Also es ist nicht once in a lifetime. Faszinierender Spieler.
Ganz offensichtlich. Und ich mag sehr den Terminus ranbaggern für Transferanbahnungen. Ich habe es für euch rausgesucht, liebe Hörer, dass ihr es nicht machen müsst. Welche Sassuolo-Spiele muss man sehen? Also Lazio, 21. Jahrzehnte werden sie gewinnen. Sie werden gegen Spezia aus der Coppa Italia ausschlagen.
Nicht auszuschließen.
Und dann gewinnen sie gegen die Roma Anfang Dezember und gegen Milan am 30. Dezember.
Am Dezember, sehe ich auch, spielen sie wieder. Insan Siro gegen Milan. Das soll sich Milan schon mal warm anziehen.
30. Dezember, wenn wir alle in der Zerwestervorbereitung sind, wenn ihr euer Essen fürs Fondue schnibbelt. Oder, na gut, da schnibbelt man gar nicht so viel, fällt mir grad auf. Na ja, egal. Das kann man sich auf jeden Fall angucken. Sassu Olo, immer ein Blick wert. Beim richtigen Gegner. So, dann sind wir aber jetzt ja eigentlich schon mitten in den Awards und bei den MVPs. Alex, wen würdest du in der La Liga zum aktuellen MVP wählen?
Ja, ich habe ihn vorhin schon genannt, den Namen. Von Girona, der Flügelspieler. Savio ist mein MVP bisher. Von ihm haben nicht so viele gehört bisher. Ich persönlich auch nicht. Leider haben wir heute keinen Frankreich-Korrespondenten hier, denn der könnte vielleicht mehr von ihm erzählen. Denn er kommt von Troye. Oder kam von Troye, ist ausgeliehen. Und deswegen wollte ich übrigens auch den Namen City Football Group nicht gleich am Anfang nennen, sondern eigentlich jetzt. Denn, Findige Hörer wissen Bescheid, Troye gehört der City Football Group. Also da wurde wieder ein bisschen der Spiele geparkt bei Girona, damit der Damen zum Einsatz kommt. Und wirklich die Entdeckung der Saison bisher unter anderem. Zwei Tore, vier Assists für Girona geschossen. Ein Brasilianer, ich glaube noch sehr, sehr jung. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie alt er ist. Also wirklich diese typischen brasilianischen Flügelstürmer fast schon. Schnell, dribbelstark, geht ins 1 gegen 1. Nicht aufzuhalten.
Warum spielt er nicht in Leverkusen?
Weil City Group wahrscheinlich. Wenn er nicht bei Troye, sondern bei Sochaux spielt oder Toulouse, dann ist er jetzt vielleicht in Leverkusen. Also das ist wirklich ein Player to watch auch in La Liga. Der macht ganz viel Spaß.
Und der MVP in der Premier League für dich aktuell, Uli?
Ja, ich habe echt lange überlegt und habe überlegt, finde ich auch irgendwie eine romantische Lösung oder so. Aber ich gehe jetzt mal wirklich auf den Wortsinn MVP, Most Valuable Player und er begründet das mit dem Bruch im Spiel nach der Auswechslung von Declan Rice bei Arsenal. Und wir müssen ja auch bei Holding Six bleiben, wenn wir schon angefangen haben. Deswegen passt das nur allzu gut. Wobei ich auch nicht so ganz sicher bin, ob das dann eine Holding Six wäre. Aber den hätte man ja in München wohl auch ganz gern gehabt. Also kurzum, wirklich ernsthaft, Declan Rice nach Verpflichtung musste sich an was Neues gewöhnen. Sehr viel mehr Ballbesitz als bei West Ham. Also sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr oder überhaupt Ballbesitz. Das gab es ja nicht unter David Moyes. Dann Umbau auf eine Einzel-Sex. Und beides hat er fantastisch gemacht. Ist für mich im Moment wahrscheinlich sogar fast der beste Sechser. Ne, streichen wir fast, ist der beste Sechser der Welt, sogar vor Rudi, weil er einen noch stärkeren… Also Holding Six kann er nicht mithalten, aber vielleicht eine Bringing Six, das ist dann eine bessere. Weil der beste Balkzirkulator im Moment in der Premier League. Ich weiß nicht, der ist einfach ein guter Spieler. Und dazu kommen noch die Dribblings, die Ballcarries. Das ist ja auch wahnsinnig wichtig, durchs Pressing durch und so. Das hat er eh immer schon relativ gut gemacht. Unterdruck, wahnsinnig stark. Wenn jetzt noch folgt, dass er torgefährlicher wird, dann ist vorbei. Und deswegen ist er für Arsenal schon so, so, so wichtig. Und man hat gesehen, was passiert jetzt schon, nach sechs Spieltagen, wenn er raus muss, wie schlecht es dann Chelsea geht.
Denen auch.
Ihr wisst Bescheid.
Vielleicht warst du schon beim Anzang Hero. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das jemand von Chelsea ist.
Denn jeder Hero, der da wäre, ist...
Nee, wer ist denn ein Anzang Hero?
Ich weiß nicht. Das fällt mir so schwer. Vielleicht musst du mir da noch mal ein bisschen geben. Ich komm nicht drauf, dass ich jetzt eine für mich zufriedenstellende Antwort gebe, die auch was Vernünftiges aussagt, ohne jetzt irgendeinen Namen zu droppen.
Gibt es jemanden bei einem Team, das eigentlich schlecht spielt, aber an demjenigen liegt es nicht? Das sind ja oft so quasi klassische Daten.
Also ich hab kurz überlegt, Dominik Kerwart-Luin zu nehmen, weil Everton jetzt gewonnen hat und er endlich wieder drauf war. Mir glaube ich, es wird nie rausgearbeitet, wie wenig die mit dem Klassenerhalt zu tun hätten, wenn der gesund wäre. Ist er halt nie. Aber würde er das sein, dann würden die automatisch Platz 14 haben. Deswegen ist das immer so, ich bin nicht glücklich mit der Aussage im Gesamten. Das, glaube ich, trifft nicht den Kern des Anzang Heroes, aber das ist der, bei dem es immer wieder war. Und da schwirrt es immer so rum. Sobald der spielt, der kann es mit jedem Einzelnen, teilweise auch mit zwei Verteidigern aufnehmen, in dieser Liga. Das heißt was. Und weil er aber dauernd verletzt ist, spricht halt nie jemand über ihn.
Ja, ich finde das passt perfekt. Christian, wer ist der Anzang Hero und der Serie A aktuell?
Sehr gut, dann gehen wir nach Bergamo, schauen wir zu Atalanta und kommen auf einen alten Bekannten aus Deutschland auch, Seyad Kolasinac. Er kam im Sommer ablösefrei von Marseille, so ein bisschen unterm Radar. Er hat letztes Jahr bei Marseille aber auch schon eine wichtige Rolle gespielt. Er trägt jetzt dazu bei, dass Atalanta defensiv sehr stabil im Moment gerade ist. Er hat die letzten drei Spiele alle gewonnen, alle zu Null gewonnen, also wettbewerbsübergreifend, auch noch mit Europa League. Und Kolasinac warum? Er hat sich gleich schon super eingefunden, ist da total fester Bestandteil und ist damage –also klar seine Physis, glaube ich, kann sich viele noch erinnern, passt auch wunderbar in dieses Gasparini-System. Aber was er ihm auch mitbringt, er ist ein Linksfuß. Und in dieser Dreierkette von Atalanta hat Gasparini in den letzten Jahren eigentlich fast immer, musste er immer, Rechtsfüße dahin basteln, quasi, weil er es nicht anders lösen konnte. Und jetzt eben hast du auf dieser halblinken Position einer Dreierkette mit Kolasinac endlich mal einen Linksfuß, der logisch auch andere Möglichkeiten, bessere Möglichkeiten im Spielaufbau gibt, der eben seine Physis, seine Athletik sowieso mitbringt. Und bei Gasperini hat den auch gleich nach den ersten Spielen schon rausgehoben, hat gemeint, seine Abgeklärtheit. Also das ist ja bei Atalanta auch nicht selbstverständlich, dass du da gleich reinfindest, denn die haben ja auch einen breiten Kader. Und deswegen, ja, für mich einen, über den nicht viel auch bei Atalanta gesprochen wird, weil klar, da ist jetzt der Ketelare, wird viel gesprochen, der vorne funktioniert, der nach diesem schwierigen Jahr bei Milan das sofort bei Atalanta jetzt eben auch getroffen hat, Vorlagen geliefert hat, Coop Mainers ist schon wieder in dieser Anführerrolle drin. Aber ich habe mir jetzt extra mal Kolasinic rausgenommen. Der passt da wunderbar rein und gibt eben Atalanta als Linksfuß da hinten so eine neue Note, die ihnen glaube ich genau gefehlt hat.
Sehr, sehr schön. Und Atalanta hat ja auch die zweitbeste Abwehr, gemeinsam mit Lecce hinter Inter. Drei Gegentore Inter und Bayern.
Und sind wieder dran jetzt auch ganz vorne.
Und sind jetzt wieder dran. Drei Punkte Rückstand. Dann brauchen wir noch einen Unsung Hero aus La Liga, Alex.
Ja, ich muss sagen, bei mir sind MVP und Unsung Hero eigentlich austauschbar. Sehr nah beieinander. Also ich hätte auch Savio einfach als Unsung Hero, weil man von dem noch nicht so viel gehört hat. Und nehme jetzt einfach Take Kubo als Unsung Hero. Hätte er auch als MVP nehmen können. Von dem hört man natürlich mehr oder den kennt man mehr. Bei Real Sociedad da wirklich eine herausragende Saison bisher. Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht, ob Nils Kern in der letzten Folge ihn vielleicht genannt hat. Das hätte nämlich Sinn gemacht.
Er hat Kubo und Isco genannt in der letzten Folge.
So, habe ich fast befürchtet, aber es ist wirklich zu rechtsspielend. Eine herausragende Saison. Hat wirklich die nächsten zwei Schritte in der Entwicklung gemacht. Ist so, so wichtig für Real Sociedad als Linksfuß auf dem rechten Flügel. Ich glaube, vier Tore in sechs Spielen. Und ist da wirklich zu einer kleinen Waffe geworden für Real Sociedad. Also auch eine ganz, ganz herausragende Saison gespielt. Macht so viel Spaß, dem zuzusehen. Ein tiefer Körperschwerpunkt, dribbelstark, abschlussstark. Also ist da wirklich in der Offensive der Schlüsselspieler von Real Sociedad geworden, würde ich sogar sagen. Tolle Form und deswegen mein Anzwang-Hiro Schrägstrich-MWP.
Sehr gut. Und welchen Moment möchtest du uns noch mitgeben, der irgendwie passiert ist in den letzten Tagen Schrägstrich-Wochen?
Moment, tu ich mich ein bisschen schwer. Ich meine, jetzt am Wochenende war natürlich die berühmte, die verrückte Remontada, also der Comeback-Sieg von Barca. Sie waren 0 zu 2 hinten hoch verdient zu Hause gegen Celta Vigo. In der 75. das 0 zu 2 kassiert. Jeder dachte sich, okay, jetzt sind sie wirklich mal fällig im Sinne von, dass sie mal wieder ein Heimspiel verlieren. Verlieren sie ja sehr, sehr selten. Es war kein guter Auftritt. Und ich glaube, in der 81., 85. und 88. drehen sie dieses Spiel. Wirklich tolle Szenen. Es war so ein bisschen Real Madrid-Feeling im Olympiastadion auf dem Montjuic. Das verloren geglaubte Spiel nach schwacher Leistung wirklich noch gedreht werden, gewonnen werden. Und da war ein Spirit in der Luft, wie man ihn ganz, ganz selten sieht. Cancelo hat eben den Siegtreffer in der 88. gemacht. Also das war so aus meiner persönlichen Sicht natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein Highlight. Aber dass sie das Ding noch drehen und nicht nur unentschieden spielen, sondern wirklich nach 0-2 in den letzten 10 Minuten 3 Tore schießen, das war schon ein ganz besonderes Spiel.
Also ich habe es aufgeschrieben, aber ich habe dazu geschrieben, Underdog siegt der Woche. Anders kann ich dir das nicht durchgehen lassen. Also ich weiß, ich weiß, das war wirklich dramatisch und die Torfolge sehr nah. Aber dass Barca ein Spiel dreht, an sich haucht mich jetzt nicht so.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, es ist ja eher Real Madrid-Style-mäßig. Man kennt es ja, wo sie nicht gut im Spiel sind, zurecht hinten liegen. Du denkst dir, dieses Spiel ist jetzt vorbei. Vor allem fällt ja sogar das 0-2 sehr spät. Da sagt man ja immer, oh, der Deckel ist drauf.
Also was er sagen will, ist lass mich.
War halt mal wieder ein besonderer Moment. Deswegen möchte ich den hier erwähnen.
Das ist ja schön, wenn du wieder was fühlen kannst bei so einem 3-2, dann ist das für mich auch der Moment.
Minimal, was man wieder gefühlt.
Ja, ich spüre es jetzt auch. Einfach magisch.
Aber um vorzugreifen, weil du willst ja immer auch das Spiel to watch besprechen, da können wir direkt vorgreifen auf das Wochenende, da empfängt Girona Real Madrid. Und vielleicht wird das ja ein besonderes Spiel, denn Girona grandios drauf. Real Madrid überzeugt fußballerisch nicht. Man hat es auch gegen Union gesehen, taten sich schwer. Ich glaube, das haben mehr Leute gesehen, dieses Spiel. Und sie haben schon letztes Jahr in Girona 4 zu 3 verloren. Da weiß Christian wahrscheinlich auch Bescheid. Tati Castellanos, der 2. Lazio, hat 4 Tore geschossen. Der ist nicht mehr da, aber die sind eben so gut drauf, dass es mich nicht wundern würde, wenn sie hier einen besonderen Sieg einfahren würden und dann hast du da ein besonderes Spiel.
Ganz kurz, Castellanos hat gestern bei Lazio reingekommen und hat fast einen Fallrückzieher-Tor des Jahres ausgepackt. Ganz knapp daneben. Das ist einer, der steht wirklich immer wieder mal gerne für Spektakel.
Gut, dann haben wir jetzt noch die Premier League. Uli, hast du einen besonderen Moment, irgendwas, was passiert ist, was hier in Erinnerung geblieben ist?
Ganz billig zwei Tore, wenn es zulässig ist. Die zu nennen sind, also zum einen Bruno Fernandes vom Samstagabend in Manchester gegen Bernley in Bernley. Weil zum einen eine herzwerbende Geschichte mit Johnny Evans, der nach 2015 wieder drauf ist für United, plötzlich einen Ball spielt. Es wäre ein richtig guter Fußballer. Und Bruno Fernandes nimmt den sensationell ab. Das ist ein wunderschönes Tor in einem fürchterlichen Spiel. Und zum anderen gestern, das ist nicht ganz zulässig, vielleicht aus dem Pokal-IFL-Cup, Dominic Soboslay, der sogenannte Thunderbastard. Den Schuss sollte man gesehen haben. Wenn man nichts an Fußball geguckt hat, das sollte man gesehen haben. Es ist einfach den Drifter perfekt. Und das ist ja kein Zufall, wie wir wissen, bei Soboslay daher, da lege ich das nahe. Und der geht so ins Tor rein, das nennt man unter gewissen Fans in England Thunderbastard.
Stark. Ich habe gestern Tweets dazu gesehen, bzw. ich glaube, es war sogar bei Mastodon. Sicher bin ich mir da jetzt gerade gar nicht. Es sind so viele soziale Netzwerke inzwischen, wo genau das thematisiert wurde. Aber ich hatte immer keine Zeit, da nach dem Video zu suchen. Jetzt muss ich es vielleicht doch machen. Man kriegt immer Hausaufgaben von euch mit. Schaut euch das 2 zu 1 an. Schaut euch das Spiel hier noch an. Und dann hier den Spieler. Naja, so ist das. Man geht hier nie mit leeren Händen raus. Gibt es denn auch ein Match-to-Watch an diesem Wochenende, Uli?
Es gibt ganz viele in der Premier League. Also das offensichtlich ist Totten im Liverpool. Das sind die beiden unterhaltsamsten Mannschaften gerade in der Liga, muss man sich, glaube ich, anschauen. Und ich nenne jetzt aber ein anderes, aus eher so persönlicher Zuneigung, das sogenannte SW6-Full-App gegen Chelsea am Montagabend um 21 Uhr. Also auch, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Zeit. Also bei Chelsea läuft es ja nicht so, wie man vielleicht inzwischen weiß. Zum einen und zum anderen ist das immer –ich mag das einfach total gern, dieses Dabi zwischen den beiden unheimlichen Nähe zueinander.
Daher kommt der SW6. Ja, okay. Dann haben wir die Premier League durch. Bleibt noch die Serie A mit einem Moment und vielleicht auch Matches to Watch.
Moment, schauen wir nochmal nach Neapel. Und zwar auch zwei Szenen da. Fangen wir an, an Uli das Tor. Also Udinese hat 2-4-1 gestern verloren. Das Tor von Samadžić lege ich auch allen nochmal ans Herz. Also ein Solo, da werden ja dann in Neapel gewisse Namen genannt, die aus Südamerika kommen. Soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen. Aber was er da ausgepackt hat, durch wie viele er sich da durchspielt und wie klasse er abschließt, also Traumtor. Aber der Moment für mich war kurz davor, ich habe Quaratzkelia vorhin schon angesprochen. Quaratzkelia hat auch einen schwierigen Saisonstart gehabt, war in der Vorbereitung verletzt, war dann am Anfang des ersten Spieltags auch nicht mit dabei. Und Quaratzkelia schwang ja schon bei vielen die Frage mit oder schwingt vielleicht immer noch bei Leuten mit, ah ja, kann der das Niveau halt nochmal halten? Also war das vielleicht letztes Jahr einfach die Saison, wo er einfach drüber war. Und gestern hat der von Anfang an, also es war jetzt wieder mal ein Heimspiel für Napoli, die waren jetzt ein paar Mal auswärts, du hast dem angemerkt, der hat von Anfang an gebrannt, der ist da rein in dieses 1 gegen 1, ich sage nicht ins 1 gegen 2, er kennt es ja auch gar nicht anders, meinst du mal 1 gegen 3, holt am Anfang den Elfmeter raus, will aber sein eigenes Tor, weil er knapp 200 Tage nicht mehr getroffen hat und du hast ihm wirklich gemerkt, der brauchte das. Packt zwei Pfosten, Treffer aus und du denkst dir, oh mein Gott, das soll einfach nicht sein. Und in der Schlussphase, ich glaube 78., macht er das 3-0, also eigentlich nicht mehr spielentscheidend, aber du hast an seinem Jubel gemerkt, wie unfassbar wichtig er ist. Ja, er ist unter die Kurve, alles ist nach. Ossi Mann auch, war schon ausgewechselt auf der Bank. Total mitgejubelt, also der hat das Tor gefeiert, als wäre es ein Tor im Champions-League-Halbfinale gewesen. Ich finde, das sind halt so Momente, wo du siehst, dass auch solche Spieler, also die auf dem Top-Niveau sind, wie sehr die dann die Momente auch brauchen. Das war so ein positiver Moment auch für Napoli, um zu zeigen, hier schaut mal her, wir haben noch so viel da. Also so viel von dem, was sonst, klar, wir werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr diese Traumsaison spielen können, aber da ist immer noch so viel Qualität da und dieses Bild von diesen wirklich sich kindlich freundenden Quaratzkele, der alles rausbrüllt, da diesen Frust, der sich aufgestaut hatte, war für mich ganz klar ein Moment und für mich auch noch zum Ende nur die Einschätzung. Ich war auch Anfang der Saison schon, also ich bin weiterhin fest davon überzeugt, dass Quaratzkele das Niveau halten kann. Also auch in den schwachen Spielen vielleicht davor, weil, warum? Er kommt über seine Athletik. Das ist ein Dribbler, aber der braucht auch den Zug dahinter. Der hat ihm halt einfach noch gefehlt, weil er eben Teil der Vorbereitung verpasst hat. Aber ich glaube, das kommt jetzt so langsam wieder. Und wie gesagt, jetzt kommen Spiele gegen Real Madrid, Champions League. Also Quaratzkele, bin ich mir sicher, wird dieses Jahr wieder groß aufzocken.
Stark. Dann brauchen wir jetzt allerletztes nur noch ein Match to Watch, wenn es denn solche gibt.
Ja, gibt auch zwei. Atalanta Juve ist am Sonntag. Da ist immer was los und beide ganz vorne dran dabei. Versuchen logisch auch, an Inter dran zu bleiben. Am Samstag ist Milan gegen Lazio. Samstag, 18 Uhr. Und da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf. Milan hat jetzt unter der Woche auch viel rotiert, hat ein wichtiges Spiel, schwieriges Spiel in Kalieri auswärts gewonnen. Nach Rückstand war ja die Frage, ob sie dieses 1.5 aus dem Derby abschütteln können. Das haben sie jetzt gemacht. Und Lazio ist so ein bisschen schleppend in die Saison gestartet, hat gestern aber gewonnen. Viele erinnern sich wahrscheinlich noch in der vergangenen Woche dieser Torhüter, der da was gemacht hat gegen Atletico, was dem einen oder anderen aufgefallen ist. Also Lazio hat bisher auch weniger eingesammelt, als sie eigentlich auch schon teilweise gezeigt haben. Und deswegen, letzte Saison waren das zwei –ich glaube, Uli, wir haben das Rückspiel gemacht in San Siro, in Milan Lazio, spät in der Saison. Da haben wir gehofft, dass Lazio viel zeigt. Da kam von Lazio kaum was, das war enttäuschend. Aber das Hinspiel, Lazio gegen Milan, die haben Lazio in dem Januar, haben Milan hergespielt. Also da war eben diese Dominanz von Lazio zu sehen. Und ich bin gespannt, ob sie da wieder hinkommen. Dementsprechend auch absolutes Spitzenspiel.
Stark. Ihr drei. Auch zu dritt schaffen wir es locker, über unserer Zeit zu landen. Einfach fantastisch. Ich danke sehr Alex Truica, Uli Hebel und Christian Bernhard. Danke euch dreien, dass ihr in der Ligatur wart. Da will keiner mehr was antworten. Ihr seid eindeutig Quatsch. Weil das Outro schon läuft, offenbar habt ihr Angst, dass ich es gleich hochziehe. Dabei dauert es noch ein bisschen, denn erst sage ich noch, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen, unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club und sagt weiter, dass es diese Sendung gibt. Gerade der Ligatur-Feed, der braucht mehr Liebe und AbonnentInnen. Danke euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Bis bald, macht's gut. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!